[Musique]
merci j faut c'est votre propre
compagnie la compagnie des ctp oui vous
avez choisi la première version du thé
absurde le honduras savannah bay j'ai
demandé à jean-claude à 1000 avec qui
j'avais fait vers à baxter de mettre en
scène et j'ai eu envie parce que je vous
mettais en scène la relation mère fille
ou air petite fille en tout cas un lien
vertigineux dans ce qui se passe entre
les mamans et nous les filles les filles
oui je trouve que c'est un texte
admirable et et ce qui avait été monté
par marguerite elle même avait été
magnifique avec madeleine madeleine
ryuji léger en 83 et nous c'est la
première version et cette première
version
à mon avis elle est peut-être plus
théâtrale les plus plus essentielles
plus viscéral à mon idée quelqu un
oratorio la version la madeleine
je pense qu'elle aurait les us oratorio
même fui et puis c'était très important
de ne pas jouer la même de se sentir à
la fois proche de de madeleine et bull
mais en même temps dans autre chose
alors que se passe-t-il dans savannah
bay des histoires d'amour oui l'histoire
le oui a les mots d'amour d'edith piaf
et mot ts mais il ya aussi les mots et
ben x et le troisième personnage on peut
dire que c'est le la chanson c'est la
présence de d'edith piaf benz et c'est
cette perte de mémoire chez la
comédienne un pin's et plumania le rôle
que je joue et car vous vous jouez
madeleine
oui madeleine renaud interpréter matane
voilà et je disais justement fabienne
j'ai beaucoup aimé beaucoup admiré
madeleine renaud avec qui j'ai beaucoup
joué quand j'étais à la
comédie-française et j'étais heureuse et
émue de rejouer un rôle de madeleine
mais pas tout à fait le même
je suis heureuse de re2 en hommage à
madeleine renaud de lui dédier ce
travail et vous avez un côté madeleine
renaud sur la scène je ne sais pas ça me
fait plaisir que si vous me le dites
puisque pour moi c'est la comédienne de
de ma jeunesse ma vie grande comédienne
qu'elle a été que j'ai aimés et admirés
et le personnage qui a été une
comédienne perd la mémoire mais par
fragments elle essaye de reconstituer la
jeune femme qui n'a pas de nom la jeune
femme on ne sait pas si c'est sa petite
fille ou un autre personnage de
marguerite duras vie dans sa préface et
c'est très joli d'ailleurs elle dit je
pense que la ligue à peu près je pense
que c'est la petite fille j'adhère à
cette version dite elle est alors moi
tout modestement moi aussi j'adhère à
cette version je pense que c'est sa
petite fille mais enfin ce n'est pas on
laisse le public décider lui même ce qui
est merveilleux chez marguerite duras
est ouvert et elle n'affirme rien elle
laisse le public pense et après tous la
version qu'il avait réussi lors d'un
drame équipe là oui bien sûr eu à donner
à sa fille elle sait qu'elle a eu un
drame dans sa vie mais elle ne sait plus
elle ne veut plus avoir
je parlais dire non 1 et va certainement
mais qu'elle ne sait pas ce qu'elle a
joués lcl c'est qu'elle est là et c'est
quand on parle de théâtre quand il y a
le théâtre c'est en fait ce qu'il a à
faire vite et cette pièce où la mort
rôde le temps ne parle que de la mort ça
n'est pas triste
et en fait elle a comme on dit quelques
quelque part dans la bible je mets
devant toi la mort et la vie choisi la
ville ait choisi la vie de toute façon
je puis j'ai chez marguerite duras je
trouve que ce qu'il y à d'absolument
magnifique c'est que c'est presque un
travail musical
il ya quelque chose qui est à la fois
dans dans ses mots dans ce qui est dit
delettrez saint extrêmement d'alain mais
le tempo est un travail complètement
musicale c'est pour ça que moi
personnellement je ne sais pas si je
suis la petite fille ou une infirmière
ou la couturière ou ça n'a pas
d'importance celle qui vient absolument
elie la ramène à la fois moi je veux
peut-être savoir à certains moments dont
je viens et qui je suis
mais ce qui compte c'est comment ces
mots arriver comment le rythme de cette
pièce se rient me pratiquement musicale
qui est qui et l'ail qui a une force
très très intenses et avec des
quotidienneté avec des trivialités
[Musique]